We are crushing our coolest
videos into bite-size pieces
for your inspiration
and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is King of Random Rewind.
10. NAPKIN ROSE
9. FLOATING PAPER CLIP
8. CANDY CATAPULT
5. SLIMY TOILET PRANK
6. RAT TRAP TREBUCHET
5. LEGO MOLD
4. SOLID LN2
3. CARBON CURRENTS
2. INVISIBLE INK
1. COLORED SMOKE
What's up, guys?
It's Grant here.
If you liked this compilation,
and want to see another one,
click the box up at the top.
If you want to see a randomly
selected video for your viewing pleasure,
click the box in the bottom.
And if you want to be a subscriber,
and you're not already in the club,
hit the bomb, and we'll
see you in the next video.